un petit tour au skatepark de ça le spot
du le survivors quête school en français
un club et une école donc il organise
des stages des événements et des
expéditions sur les différents skate
parc de l'île bref ils passent tout leur
temps sur leur skate
l'un d'eux laurent jans et champion de
la réunion
rencontre avec sébastien laurent julien
et loane le survivor sur leurs terres
moi tout ce que j'essaie de faire ici à
saint lô de la réunion s'est passé
recréer un petit peu ce que j'ai connu
avec mes pairs voilà qu'ils avaient
cinq six ans de plus que moi qui étais
des championnats qui m'ont
communiquer cette passion du skate et
ses 23 ans et voilà j'espère que
j'arrive à bien la communiquer au sein
de mon club et donc on essaie développé
un petit peu à la pratique sur sa 2e et
puis nous arriver aussi de faire d
organiser des manifestations sur deux
sur l'ouest que nord le nord-est
comme l'année dernière on a fait
championnat de la réunion cette année on
se consacre plusieurs activités au club
il ya le l'école de skate donc à des
cours tout ça le mercredi samedi pour
les publics à ces débutants
on essaye tous les week-ends de partir
avec les plus grands les confirmer
qu'ils sont une partie avec moi ici et
on essaie de partir sur des spots de
street donc
qui est la source un peu du skate 1
qu'est né un petit peu dans
et même carrément dans la rue sans
grandeur utilisateurs sensibilisés par
le train de vie secteur a dévalisé
martyrs dans la moiteur les alizés
moteur immense fortune ray
amateur de mes lettres et les colis six
frappeurs bourg avait croqué frénésie
gros bon sens et syndicats général on a
pu voir ça en france il ya une dizaine
d'années c'est à dire qu'on a affaire à
des structures à la réunion qu'ils sont
pas adaptés ou mal adapté au public à la
pratique inquiète aussi au climat
donc c'est vrai que ça fait à peu près
cinq ans qu'on a un skate parc à saint
leu si un petit peu la tronche on va
dire mais c'est vrai que on a un petit
peu de mal à se faire entendre par
rapport à l'entretien qui doit être fait
régulièrement sur ces sites
il
concrètement la culture skate à la
réunion en dehors du street
on se dirige depuis quelques temps et
c'est un bon virage qu'on a pris vers
vers un encadrement quelque chose de
très de présentateur
pour avec 7 par exemple dans son club
qui va justement encadrer les plus
petits pour plus accroché parce que le
skate est un sport très très très dur et
ingrat
si on a beau avoir dix ans de pratique
20 ans de fatick
on se fait toujours mal et les messages
illisibles au portable le plus
insupportable avec tu joue là bas on
voit pas vraiment l'aixois les défauts
les qualités lot seule chose qu'on veut
partager si les sept bons moments et
c'est ça la culture du skate c'est un
style de vie une culture si tu partages
en toute simplicité commence par le
scrabble tape sur les nerfs de nos
talents prometteurs
on va dire il ya laurent jans qui était
partie aux championnats de france aussi
le champion n'a réuni que j'aime bien ce
qui était avec eux parce que le pousse à
faire toutes sortes de choses que l'on
appelle un peu le crash test parce que
ce que personne va faire mais il y aura
toujours moi qui va le faire et c'est ça
qui me motive pour apprendre
en fait lors de notre savoir-faire qu'on
connaît
mais en fait c'est ça le but c'est
partager un bon moment
et puis s'amusait pas
m